it's a video which is as haunting as it
is troubling the gunman strolling
towards the classroom where he'll murder
19 children and two teachers terrorizing
many more
kimberly and felix's ten-year-old
daughter lexi was among those shot dead
hearing
shots fired into our classroom
there are no words i mean to the world
who viewed it
they were watching
a deranged person shooting into an
obscured classroom
but to us
we could see and hear him murdering
my child
bereaved families relived the horror of
that day from washington dc where
they're campaigning for an end to gun
violence they watched police officers
gathered outside the classroom they're
carrying guns wearing body armor even
ballistic shields their training makes
it clear they should confront the threat
immediately and yet they wait
even applying hand sanitizer
you often hear the argument of good guys
with guns i think we saw in
the video
that's not true
yes that's not true
we had police officers tasked with
protecting our children that day and
they failed because they were afraid to
go in because this man had an assault
weapon
if the police officers who are armed and
trained do not want to face this person
that had an assault weapon who does
lexi's parents are lobbying lawmakers to
ban assault rifles somewhere to channel
their grief i put her in that classroom
and i failed to take her home after the
award ceremonies
and now she's dead
and her mom
it's on me
[Applause]
i don't know how to live with that it's
not it's not on you though it's really
really hot on me
the what-ifs are almost too much to bear
but really the only question that
matters is what it will take for america
to decide enough is enough martha
kellner sky news washington